China's spies have got a lot of unwanted
attention recently thanks in part to
political and trade tensions between
China and the US many of those spies
work for the country's main intelligence
agency the Ministry of State Security or
MSS in December 2018 one of China's top
tech executives was arrested in Canada
on a US extradition request
soon after MSS agents abruptly detained
two Canadians in China then days later
the u.s. publicly named two of MSS as
alleged assets as part of a sweeping
u.s. indictment involving hacking on a
global scale
the series of events has people asking
what exactly is the MSS this is your
bloomberg quick take on China's elusive
spies compared with the u.s. the MSS is
something of a mash-up it conducts
intelligence operations abroad like the
CIA counter espionage at home like the
FBI and cyber snooping like the NSA when
you hear the details of how the MSS
operates you think it wouldn't be out of
place in a spy movie the number of
employees is classified and the exact
location of its headquarters isn't
unknown though it's thought to be an
anon descript building in Beijing it
doesn't have a public website and it
doesn't have a press office what's clear
is that the MSS is key to Chinese
President Xi Jinping's efforts to
tighten control over security its head
Chen wen Qing is an ex police chief who
helped direct Xi's nationwide anti-graft
campaign in 2015 the national security
law extended the MSS as power to outer
space and the deep sea as well as the
Internet
the MSS benefits from close ties between
the state and Chinese tech giants like
Baidu and Alibaba and Tencent all of
which have the ability to mine personal
data other government departments are
required to cooperate with the MSS and
provide support for its activities the
MSS operates secret detention facilities
within China and is known for its harsh
treatment of dissidents for example the
blind civil rights lawyer Chen
Guangcheng
was under house arrest for 19 months
before he fled to the US Embassy in
Beijing in 2012 and eventually moved to
New York so the organization has
developed a fearsome reputation and
that's based on how much power it has on
the vague limitations on that power
detainees including foreigners have
alleged violations of their basic rights
while in the custody of security agents
and some have talked about daily
six-hour interrogations not having
access to lawyers or confinement in
cells under lights that never seem to go
out
media reports have noted some key MSS
victories including the possibility that
they monitored president Donald Trump's
calls made on unsecured cellular devices
there was also a report that the MSS had
dismantled CIA operations in China over
several years killing a dozen or more of
the agency's sources reportedly in one
of the worst US intelligence breaches in
decades this isn't an organization
that's completely immune to the global
microscope a senior MSS officer was
arrested in Belgium and extradited to
the US and 2018 on charges of conspiring
to steal trade secrets from top 80 Asian
companies but you have to remember this
is still an organization that's very
powerful that was reportedly the very
first time a spy for China's government
had ever been brought to America to face
charges
[Music]
you